oh I time let's get excited into the
meme drawers the Peter Parker and Joker
mean my two redhead followers
I might not seen this before either way
it's so awesome
I made the hundred million YouTube
button PewDiePie deserves to get out of
deserves to get comma out of carbon
fiber that looks sick like that looks
amazing that really suits it with a red
tear that looks really dope I know a lot
of people are criticizing this one I
wish you didn't leave so many
fingerprints so I can actually hold it
without wearing gloves but I still think
this is actually really cool I can see
the views right in front of me don't
worry YouTube I've fixed it
just like I'm still happy YouTube's m1
but that is a very cool one too that's
all I'm gonna say PD PI doesn't have a
controversy for months and is at peace
with the media his fan base fine I'll do
it myself
appreciate you guys so much beautifly is
enjoying life being married living
ethically but we haven't seen Papa
Gloria in a while to me 100 million just
signified the turning point which
happened to coincide almost perfectly
with his wedding in his life he's ready
to be stable and just establish
illimitably Shawn as we make the motor
send from a business point it was not a
business standpoint I make a great
living I know everyone's think I'm a
greedy bastard which I am but no I Weiss
where I swore I swore I made a
subscriber count for Felix but can they
do this oh my god ah whoa
Brian lo more like Brian goes low when
he benches a water thing counter down
over 100 million subscribers subscribe
that's really cool oh yeah I'm on my own
account now I can upvote no wait I can
see the thing is like everyone just goes
why does he not upload we
automatically YouTube shows these dumb
reports of like oh look
fakie we're in the endgame killed loved
ones ethics weird army epic ultimate
goals epic becomes a farmer epic you
know Thanos is my favorite character
from all the Marvel films he's the best
I love him absolute badass still kills
people like a ding dong what happens
when after farming them Oh God
oh no I'm gonna get their dose myself
I'm gonna get thin and also dealings you
came back the council has been
overthrown I've seen this before it
costs 400 Thomas has never seen such BS
before maybe this is not the best timing
but we also have now the hundred million
edition it glows in the dark how many
chairs do you have that glows in the
dark
if the answer is zero when you need to
do something about that and I know
everyone's been saying 399 Felix that is
such a good price well I got you an even
better price instead of 500 49.99
it's for $69.99 and that's a nominal
full price I love this mean for Matt and
I mean Mars I recently started watching
the office and it's so good I feel like
I'm finally getting in touch with all
the kids like I finally watched Joe Joe
I find let me watch end game I finally
watched the office I'm like I understand
the memes I was thought she was like a
stalker or something but they're
actually together epically people who
sign up for the 51 raid it's happening
in five days Frick oh my god it will
happen when this video go up I think oh
my god it will happen afterwards I'm so
excited for the shift show that's about
to happen
Felix will we get a 20-19 closet review
I generally enjoy this hello and welcome
to my wardrobe welcome to my closet see
you next year
I haven't updated my water of that much
to be honest but I'm glad you guys like
them I'm wearing right now the hand
captain 2019 epic 100 mil March I just
wear my own March instead it's more
lucrative PT Pi playing with the
jacksepticeye oh dear oh dear gorgeous
pipe language cinnamon toast get you
freaky I don't think this is accurate
when I play with Jack I'm trying to kill
him there has to be another template
that suits this hey can I copy your
homework sure just make it look
different so it doesn't look like you
just copied it sure thing I mean I think
that was the point that they were going
with the same aesthetic but I think we
can all recognize the hero of the mug ok
Bros Brawl faced cop he'll be back
Pokemon go minecraft Earth B's mad did
you guys hear that did you guys see
something B when it's already September
and you haven't seen any hype before the
raid since July 30 PI it's urgent
hey do you guys see the article that
said hey if anyone dives from area 51
its PewDiePie's fault plain PewDiePie
when someone dies okay someone wrote
this I made PewDiePie fighting t-series
this took three months to finish and
also Watership is in the end
what am i doing these are all hand-drawn
that's so cool
is this a a tracing of one punch man or
whatever I watching I'm very confused
because someone did that once and
everyone get really angry
use code PewDiePie for 30% Wow but the
great price still very impressive
very nice oh what a joy if Felix is
Swedish and so are meatballs and
Marseille is Italian and so spaghetti
then Felix plus marcia equals spaghetti
and meatballs this is so nice and
wholesome and they makes me so glad
through love everyone spaghetti and
meatballs so nice the first guy to ever
watch pity pie video must have been like
probably not it was probably me actually
that was me look how funny I'm screaming
bing bang bong new announcement in
beginning a video now it's really cursed
just kidding that's embarrassing
we're on it be in touch a little bit of
glue and it's like brand-new flex glue
clear can definitely fix it flex glue
can get the job done I I want flex screw
clear I want nothing else touching my
award my precious award I feel the power
surging through me Oh wheels on shopping
card be like haha hey sticker take deco
surprise tickle we're still doing the
tickle
maybe tickle isn't appropriate how about
just fingering
is that good you got a little something
on your face there sorry let me there
you go that's better
it's a HQ watching the under Philip play
button break I swear I didn't do
anything with it God creating PewDiePie
okay oh it's lunch time send him down
tap that's cool
apparently in Irish is an expression
that your leg less means that you're
just drunk so if I'm legless does that
mean I'm always drunk that's epic oh my
god the new regime that's the darkest
fat out I have ever seen Jesus Christ
all right maybe the one where I kill the
young Lynx is worse but I mean what I
made it to David you can prove it what I
can play it now what oh here we go
developed by grimsy 709
alright basic basic step I like the
music
oh look it's I can't our I got no legs
this is epic
all right jumping [ __ ] and then what I
do with Z&X I don't know we'll find out
hey I'm in Minecraft gamers ah how do i
attack there we go
I've almost dead this is not epic can I
get up here my legs too tiny this is
like 2d minecraft just like terraria Wow
alright we're spending come on Sven I
can double click to run faster more
melons epic chop chop chop chop chop
chop chop chop chop chop there we go
ah stop shop oh god I'm gonna die
Madeline chop-chop-chop-chop
shrink I'm almost dead dude this is
embarrassing
if I die at my own game I die in real
life okay we got melons make sure I
don't fall down in a death trap
oh god oh oh the creeper helped me Thank
You creeper oh yeah IKEA boy whoo we let
the Tower of IKEA so beautiful my god
cool if I sit here you can't hit me oh
no oh I'm still alive somehow it's kind
of hard to jump without legs are you
kidding me I died in my own game this is
so sad I'll never even get to meet Sven
I'll play it I'll play when I have more
time that's really cool incredible job
go on Felix I won't bore you with every
step of the journey yeah I got time the
point was that you followed their
journey why would a fly land on
something like this rats should be
ashamed for falling in this trap bears
this is ridiculous
potatoes this way so stupid
although Hajduk just goes with it the
first person to get to bridge simulator
must have been like that's a great price
no it should have been what that's the
first thing right
that's adorable
brofist bro tickle bonus protocol
surprise protocol
finger-licking pickle you tell me which
one you preferred pity pie
I think I forgot something European
viewers if you forgot that it wasn't
important
pity pie yeah you're right American
viewers Petey pyres live quick minecraft
stream 450 5 a.m. I had such a fun time
during that livestream
I never streamed for more than like a
couple hours I'm sorry
not everyone got to catch it I would
have done on the weekend but I've been
so busy it was hard for me to find a
time to do it and a slot open up and I
just decided to take it and I thought
I'd leave it's better than nothing Felix
and Jack should have a chest cold swore
jar then you have to put a diamond in
when you swore that's right I saw this
and we did it based on this
recommendation and I love that
yeah Africa creeper Ben is sexy ash over
a big begging for it deeper Oh spaghetti
music stops spaghetti music goes up hey
tell us forget it musica he'd be begging
for a deeper bleep up yeah Africa
creeper he'd be begging for it deeper
when I see a creeper I said oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh man yeah we got a music
toilet [ __ ] ah oh sorry I was in the
window there it is
[Music]
yeah Africa creeper oh okay buried
deeper every costume shop who sells
Naruto custom one day before area51 rain
stinks well if you haven't got your if
you haven't got your Naruto outfit I got
you a great deal I check out to get out
market we have the official Naruto space
edition sweater item ships mid-september
that's perfect
I was so happy with a make it I made
these patches
I thought they turn out great beautify
his lime beautify his live quick
minecraft stream 12-hour live stream
oh god people gonna complain so much I
thought it was funny but then I realized
I just made everyone confused to be like
boy it's just the 12 hour live stream
here I live in through a highlight for
you right here it I think I think there
was two moments and the entire live
stream that was funny
like crazy number one was that I
discovered his skeleton spawn right next
to my house and I was like this is
awesome so I decided to build a mob farm
or a spawn forum and I never built one
before so I had to follow this tutorial
and it took like it was kind of
frustrating because it wasn't very good
tutorial as well I gotta say soon it
just me yeah we're five hours in almost
six hours in I'm almost done and I can't
people be like you should do something
else I'm like no that payoff is gonna be
worth it
so it's bling on hardcore as well so if
you die in hardcore it's obviously over
we just place away my items in case I
die Wow
foreshadowing Felix you've got to watch
my weight everyone no I would never make
such a noob mistake I did for it was
done and I forgot to remove a torch and
then he got all dark and I decided to
just go through it let me hold this in
my friend and then they pushed me in my
own trap no oh so bad
five hours wasted the second funny
moment 10 hours in when you got ranking
me and Jack played Minecraft on our
server are you telling me the dog is a
fake I would actually like mice crazy as
it sounds I would actually like to do
another 12 I realized she me a pretty
pie veteran watching Felix narrate his
story for the beginning this is
beautiful
oh thanks gamers the first guy to break
the red diamond button
have been like congratulations you're
now having more subscribers in these
tubers pewdiepie minecraft veterans
watching PewDiePie become a Minecraft
expert because of them rights my
glorious creation rice don't worry it
still took me an hour to build a mob
spawner so I'm not quite there yet
monitor companies when peers change
brofist to bro tickle not strings oh
yeah was it sir on ik I think I saw him
upload you broke in for nothing how did
real for what fine give me your orders I
don't need to tell you about the journey
you already knew it
from oh my god stop
why would explode it at the end that's
crazy
thank you sir Nick this one's just for
you nobody
not a single soul minecraft resource
pack creators why do you never use the
resource pack well because because of
this when only one person shows up to
raid era 51 it's beef smash 264 my god
we're screwed
pack up boys we're running huge makes
minecraft series pure news ah yeah it
will it will go up today so ender pearls
are clearly not under my knives they are
wrong color what if they are they're
testicle is that would explain why you
don't get ender pearl every time that
was under woman but could mean it hurt
Ben Hur and their titties what if and
their man drops and their pearls as in
plural and their titties and if they
drop and if the ender pearl only drops
one testicle
does that mean it's a hit Poots after 12
hour life seem sleep sleep yeah I was
very tired I still feel tired
congratulations PewDiePie for 100 minute
oh my god Peppa Pig my heart goes out to
you thank you so much remember this guy
this is him now feel proud yet all hey
dad be cool actually I do quite like
that Haseman we cool prefers the exact
same meal for the 327 time Edgar my yeah
I show this de marzi and she was so
confused but also she laughed
thanks for making her laugh gamers made
a render appearance logic Sven that is
so cute when Felix breaks the
hundred-million play button to get a
custom play button I used to play button
to get the play button hey Felix I
finally did it I started watching your
videos in 2014 and they eventually
started helping me with self-harm eating
disorder issues that I had i watch your
videos whenever I felt the urge to hurt
myself and they would distract me from
the pain I was feeling aside
now I'm proud to say I haven't self
hardening for months when I was
hospitalized for depression last year I
bought your book that feels out of
nowhere solemn keep saying strong I'm
proud of you where is it Salem what I
don't know boys boys playing Minecraft
girls but I don't really review this
meme even all right gamers time to end
that episode there if you enjoy my shirt
you know where to check it out and
thanks to you for all the love and
support I really appreciate it and I'll
see you guys next time
row finger